Hi there. And welcome to this Rawkode byte.
In this episode, I'm gonna take a look
at the traceroute command and try to help
you understand what is actually happening at the
packet and networking level to make that traceroute
work.
So let's take a quick look at this
small diagram I put together.
When we make a request to google.com
from our machine,
it's not a straight line to google.com.
There is other networking devices typically routers and
switches in between
which have to forward on our request until
we get where we need to be.
So not uncommon for something to leave your
machine at some sort of local rare before
eventually getting to some exchange,
before eventually getting to some other return, before
finally getting to the website
or you know IP address that you've requested.
Each time we hit a new device, we
call this a hop.
Now,
our machines, operating systems don't want to send
packets and wait an infinite amount of time
for a response.
So they apply something called a TTL, a
time to live on every packet that leaves
the machine.
Let's assume
that the TTL
on a packet that we are about to
hypothetically send
is two.
We send it from our machine and it
gets to the yellow router.
The yellow router will decrement the TTL from
two to one and forward the packet to
the next machine.
Once that packet gets to the pinky red
router, it's gonna decrement the TTL. It's gonna
go from one to zero.
When that device sees the TTL zero and
knows that we're getting up, we're not gonna
forward it onto anymore machines.
So it will actually respond
to my machine to say hey,
this expired.
A trace route takes advantage of this mechanism
of the TTL
and when you run a trace route instead
of applying the default TTL from your operating
system, which is typically a value of anywhere
from 64 to 255,
then it sets the TTL to one.
What that means is our machine will speak
to the yellow router. The yellow router will
decrement the TTL from one to zero and
the yellow router will respond.
Now our machine knows a little bit about
that hop.
It will then increment the TTL to two.
This time we reach the pinky red router
and we get a little bit of information
about that. Our machine will continually increment that
TTL until it hits our target machine and
we get not we get back a normal
response.
So what does that look like when we
run the traceroute command? Well,
I have performed a traceroute to google.com.
We can see the first hop is my
local router and it's pretty fast and we
get information back because that router responds to
the ICMP ping.
There's another networking device after my router which
did not respond.
That's why we get star star star. It's
important to note that that isn't a problem.
It just means that device didn't really want
to answer the request.
However, if we go on with another TTL
slightly larger, we had this next device. We
get another device that doesn't respond and then
we get a few more on and on
and on. We can see that it takes
nine hops before we reach google.com.
And we can see the round trip time
and milliseconds for each of these connections.
Giving us an idea of where problems are
when we make a request for a certain
website. We can narrow it down based on
information that we get back from the hops
And that's how traceroute works.
I hope you found that useful. There'll be
more episodes soon. Have a great day.